Speaker 1: Well, my friends, we are getting
dangerously close to the 2022 midterm elections.
Debates are in full swing. We have multiple
debates that I will be livestreaming this
week and next week and the week after. And I want
to start today with three important races where
we have either a debate to talk about or a public
appearance or something. We will first talk about
Texas governor, which is incumbent Republican Greg
Abbott versus Democratic challenger Beto O'Rourke.
We will then talk about Republican Senator from
Florida, Marco Rubio, the incumbent against the
challenger, Democratic Congresswoman Val Demings,
who has won the Democratic primary and is now
facing Marco Rubio. And then we will talk about a
very important race, Pennsylvania gubernatorial,
where the Democratic candidate, Josh SHAPIRO,
is facing off against the Republican nominee,
Doug Mastriano. And Mastriano is one of
the most dangerous and extreme candidates,
and he is also cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs. But we
will get to that. Let's not get to the Cocoa
Puffs right away. Let's start with Greg
Abbott. We did a livestream on YouTube,
Twitch and Facebook last week of this debate.
The debate is the incumbent Republican governor
of Texas, Greg Abbott, against the challenger,
Beto O'Rourke. And we actually did learn a lot
about Greg Abbott during this debate,
including undeniable confirmation that
Abbott is a completely disgusting and a
completely immoral and dishonest person,
which is sort of like the trifecta for Republicans
in 2022. Let's start with the first clip. In this
clip you will see Greg Abbott when presented with
the reality about abortion in the world. He says,
listen, you know, we're trying to get people
baby supplies so you don't really need access to
abortion. When you've got baby supplies, do you?
Speaker 2: Is Plan B the alternative when it comes
to somebody who is pregnant from rape or incest?
Speaker 3: Well, it depends on what you mean by
alternative. An alternative, obviously, is to
do what we can to assist and aid the victim,
and that is to help get them medical assistance
that they need and the care that they need,
but also to know what their options are.
They're going to know that the state there are
Alternatives to abortion program provides living
assistance, baby supplies, all kinds of things
that can help them. Also, we've increased funding
for prenatal, prenatal and postpartum care.
Speaker 1: Listen, guys, if you are and I
shouldn't say guys because it's not guys, listen,
if you are in the situation where you are raped
by a family member and you become pregnant. Sure,
you might think that what you want is to
decide for yourself with the Council of
Medical Professionals that you might want to
not carry that pregnancy to term. We have this
alternative where we'll give you baby supplies
after you're forced to birth the baby. This is
Republicans in 2022. Now they deserve to suffer
electoral losses as a result of this complete and
utter insanity. Whether they will is a different
question, and I don't actually know the answer
right now. Also during this very same debate, Greg
Abbott got caught lying. Just straight up lying.
Here is Greg Abbott claiming he didn't coordinate
that. Rather, he denies that he didn't coordinate
these political stunts where they sent immigrants
to different democratically run cities. He just
straight up gets caught lying. Check this out.
Speaker 3: Governor, I want to talk to you. You
talked about migrants and the busing of migrants.
Many migrant advocates and Democratic elected
officials have expressed concerns about the
treatment of migrants being bussed from Texas
to other states and cities. Here's New York Mayor
Eric Adams talking about that just last week.
Speaker 1: Yep.
Speaker 4: And when we reached out to
Governor Abbott, they stated, can we coordinate?
Can we unify? You know who's traveling here and we
don't have to guess this. They refuse to do so.
Speaker 3: The White House has called this a
political stunt. Governor Abbott, is
this a political stunt? And has there
been coordination with the states and cities
these migrants are being taken to? And if not,
why not? You have 60 seconds. So this operation
began after a meeting with local officials.
Speaker 1: The sheriffs understand how slick that
is. He says, we have coordinated we coordinated
with local officials here in Texas. No, no,
no, no. But, Greg, the issue is, why didn't you
coordinate with the people in the cities where you
were sending the migrants? He tries to slip. No,
we spoke to all sorts of people here in Texas.
Speaker 3: Now, mayors, police chiefs and county
judges were they were overrun with the number of
migrants that Border Patrol had dumped into to
their tiny little communities. They needed
relief. And bussing was one of the ways of
providing them relief and thus begin the
process of bussing the migrants to cities
that self-identified as sanctuary cities.
Mayor Adams has never called my office,
never talk to anybody in my administration.
Speaker 1: And that is a lie. We now have
the receipts. Thankfully, Fabian Levy, who is the
press secretary to New York City Mayor Eric Adams,
published emails with redacted email
addresses where you just very clearly,
very, very clearly see, there are email chains.
We have one up on the screen right now. They did
attempt to communicate and it was Greg Abbott that
opted not to quickly proven to be a complete and
total lie. Better. We'd have, quite frankly, a
very strong closing statement and really puts
significant pressure on Abbott on the issue of
doing nothing about firearms violence in Texas.
Speaker 2: We'll start with
you tonight. 30 seconds for
your closing statement. Your time starts now.
Speaker 3: Thank you. Look, I don't think that
Greg Abbott wakes up wanting to see children shot
in their schools or for the grid to fail. But it's
clear that he's incapable or unwilling to make
the changes necessary to prioritize the lives of
our fellow Texans. That's why it's on all of us
to make sure that we have change at the ballot
box this November 8th. I'll keep your lights on.
I'll make sure they keep your kids safe or reduce
property taxes, and we'll prioritize the lives
of each and every single Texan in this state.
Speaker 1: All right. So, by the way, the
debate was a total disaster in terms of the
format. There were times where the candidates
were given 15 seconds to respond to something.
It's you know, it's one of these things where the
format becomes an enemy of itself, where in order
to stick to this arbitrary format, they completely
ruin the possibility of any deep discussion on
any issue. So unfortunately, we didn't really
learn very much other than confirming some of
the horrible things we suspected about Greg Abbott
going in. Now one interesting thing, KXAN out of
Austin, Texas did a focus group before and after
the debate and they had them watch the debate. The
debate itself turned a whole bunch of that room in
favor of Beto O'Rourke. So check this out. This is
the start and you'll see them put up the numbers.
Speaker 2: You guys had a lot to say during.
During the focus group, we were able
to track your reactions in real time.
But before our debate this evening, we polled
you with a couple of questions. And one of the
responses that we got we want to share
with you now, we have a graphic to show
you. This is how you voted if we as we get.
Speaker 1: So the way that the focus group
voted before the debate was, 40% said they plan to
support Greg Abbott. 27% said they plan to support
Beto and 33% were undecided. I'm just going to
skip through the 2 minutes of stuff that they talk
about and just show you these final results. After
the debate, the Abbott number was at 43%. Betto
had exploded to 50% support in the. Room, leaving
only 7% undecided. So that's the good news on this
race. The not so good news is that the the polling
in general isn't very good for better. But again,
the idea is the debate might change that. On
average, it is Abbott plus eight looking at
official polling in that race. So if you live in
Texas, a very important race for you to vote in.